so we're about to go on an ATV ride I'm
all geared up I've got about like five
jackets on right now they're just so
easy outside
so I can't even tell you it like this
this is extreme a TV like this wasn't
just like a we're gonna go for a
leisurely ride on a trail this is over
on a mountain run occasionally they just
put its roommate huh oh my god I hope
he's cooking that's a great idea
all right so we I would say we just got
done doing the ATV tour but we've been
here for a couple of hours because I was
so cold I couldn't even speak and as you
can tell by my coffees I am running one
two three four I just got my fifth so
I'm like I'm five and deep in coffee
right now Jenna had to drive and she's
falling asleep right now because I was
sure it was exhausting to drive you
around I'm gonna just copy I'll see you
guys either tomorrow or the next day or
in this clip there'll be more videos I
don't know I'm she started to think
about my editing process right now